[Music]
we can't go any further yeah there's
gotta be some way
[Music]
what's that
I can sense the ancient tongue we're
near one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the guy you're good
all right then I'll be taking her sword
let's have it
[Music]
well that was easy well then we gotta
get back to work thanks so much
[Music]
we went through all that trouble and we
can't see the pedestal is that what
you're thinking well sorta hey what are
you doing being invisible has its
benefits seriously
[Music]
hey sarey come over here
what is it sir a
[Music]
Elesha
is that you sir a welcome and who may
this be this is Sir eh
ah yes the one who rescued our princess
way out there in the ruins
sir eh this is lady mal Tran
she's been appointed as the committee
leader for the festival this year she is
also the one who taught me the way of
the spear nice to meet you I'm sorry it
is a pleasure by any chance did you come
here to attempt the trial of the blade
not just that to tell you the truth
what this mysterious organization has
told you is true there are indeed those
who think less than favorably of me but
even so I cannot live my life in fear of
them
but what Alisha thank you so much sir eh
I really appreciate your concern
soon the finale of the festival the
flames of purification will begin please
enjoy yourselves
[Music]
so this is what states people deal with
she didn't even flinch oh that's right
check out the pedestal though right
[Music]
[Music]
if no one else can see her does that
mean she's a seraph you probably can't
remove the sword unless you can speak
with her
meaning no ordinary person can do it
incredible so that means the legends
were true hey say something to me unless
you want me looking like a total weirdo
but still ladies and gentlemen my fellow
citizens of Lady Lake for the past
several years we have abstained from our
beloved festival in light of the general
state of the world but this year thanks
to the grace and assistance of our lady
Alicia the sacred blade festival can be
held once more
[Music]
we yet live in a time of crisis violent
weather geopolitical tensions pestilence
famine the list goes on
[Music]
however I believe that it is precisely
times such as these that make our
cultural traditions and celebrations all
the more vital to maintain a wondrous
Lady of the lake show us your power
[Music]
Oh merciful Lady of the lake hear our
plea cleanse us of our sins and woes
with your flames of purification
[Music]
citizens of Lady Lake this jubilant
festival shall be as a prayer to the
heavens that we may know peace and
prosperity some prayer all right this
prayer of yours gonna give us our jobs
back the council already ceased the
crops of weaponry trades for the state
they might as well declare war and get
it over with
hey lady you try to kill us this ain't
nothing but the council given itself a
pat on the back
well we're not gonna stand for it find
someone else to lick your boots toilets
do not disturb the festival enough
ah certs you right
this whole riot was the center
look at that guard
the Chancellor
place to protect in a power struggle
will be really so corrupt Oh shucks
it's a safety No
you go in people's hearts its rise to
malevolence
a certain point
lady of the ledger
not good but those flames out the black
flames are part of the hell units
regular ones
sorry she really can't assume
our
or given to those who
to become my sword is to serve as a
vessel for me to dwell in and to assume
the Shepherd's burden blessed with the
power of purification and abilities
beyond human Ken thirsts to be scorned
by others and wrought with the sand to
protect this land from the habían means
a constant stream of agonizing decision
it is a lonely battle the likes of which
you can scarcely imagine that's the
burden of the Shepherd and you want
already to take all that on right here
and now it is not to be done lightly may
I ask you your name oh of course I am
Lila Lila my dream is to investigate
ancient ruins all over the world I
believe that the legends of the past
hold knowledge about how humans and
seraphim might one day live in harmony
together I must find a way to make that
happen to bring humans and Seraphim
together again as it was in the days of
yore
if purifying the Hellions
save both humans and Seraphim and
then it's the best chance I'll ever have
to make that dream a reality are you
really okay with this three that's why
I shall become the shepherd I shall bear
your word
[Music]
corruption a shiny
sir a take up and or you got it
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
three is that really you get back Alicia
hey you'll be able to handle the
Hellions right yeah just take care of
the rest of the flames
we do become a Hogan I can take care of
those slimes with my fire purify them
with the Shepherd's power guards
focus your effort
what no Dre are are you really
yep hi I'm the Shepherd now
[Music]
calm yourselves at once Chancellor
Bartlow
lady Alicia we received word that there
was a civil disturbance among the
commoners indeed however it has already
been quelled by the appearance of the
Shepherd
the shepherd you say
citizens of Lady Lake I hereby announce
that this year's sacred blade festival
has come to a close you heard him
clear out at once milady
I should like to ask the cause of all
this at a later time lady mouse ran your
presence is also requested
the Shepherd of all things
now then it is time for me to return to
my place within you oh yeah I am the
vessel after all now that's a creepy
sight what that it's sarey what's wrong
it's because I have entered his body I'm
afraid you'll have a high fever lasting
about three full days
what why presumably the human body is
reacting to the sudden presence of
unknown powers inside of it those who
make a path through the therapy usually
wind up bedridden for a time so that's
what happens to one who becomes a vessel
but I don't feel so good
Hey are you alright not really
I think I'll take a nap
you
you